we all know family can be a bit
challenging and Mesopotamian gods are
known for taking it to the extreme their
mythology has quite the history of
ancestral murder let's start with
primordial freshwater deity apsu who was
slaughtered by his great-grandson IA who
turned his corpse into his dwelling
place because nothing says love like
crafting your home out of the dead body
of your relative although apsu wasn't
totally innocent he did propose killing
his own annoying Offspring first but
still then there's esan Marduk who would
follow in his Father's Footsteps killing
his great-great-grandmother Tiamat the
primordial deity of saltwater poor lady
already housed the entirety of Creation
in her womb and now this to add insult
to injury Marduk also uses her corpse as
the building block for new Realms he
uses her body to create the heavens and
the Earthly world like father like son I
guess